Ladies and gentlemen. Jeff Novitsky. How
are you buddy? What's Up Gel? Doing good.
You have to ask you, do you mind
the nickname the golden snitch?
So first thing I was going to bring up
this golden snitch bullshit.
I just want to say it's not my nickname.
It's Brennan jobs.
He came up with it 100% on his own. It was
going to ask you. It's all good though.
It's good. It's all good. So a couple
of funny stories about that. So I don't,
when did he come up with this?
About a year ago at least. So,
so people in the office started
coming up to me saying, hey,
golden snitch and what the hell is that?
Do a little research as she something
about Harry Potter or some character named
there. I'm like, what the hell does this
have to do with me? So about a month ago,
somebody lets me know,
hey, checkout Wikipedia.
So for whatever reason there's
a Jeff Novitsky Wikipedia page.
You go to that page. Now it says,
says, actually my formal name,
Jeffrey John Lovitz,
he aka the golden snitch.
So last week, dawn and mark,
Eleni, you know, Donna, um,
long 15 year employee of the UFC now
works with me and talk about her a little
later. It's a great asset to what we're
doing. She sends me a text, she says,
check this out.
So she's got one of those Amazon Echos.
Um, Alexa, I think so. She says Alexa,
who's Jeff Novitsky and
Alexis name says Jeffery.
John Novitsky Aka the golden snitch.
So thanks a lot. Shop Shove. What have
you done? That's hilarious. I love Donna.
She's amazing. She's awesome.
So she's over there. I mean,
you know about kind of her history.
She's more of the five original employees
of UFC was Dane as assistant to start
out with, uh, went on to become VP
of event operations. So basically,
you know, she got everybody to the
event set up hotel at the event,
ran the crew, you know, the
blue shirts backstage that
run the event. Um, you know,
I think after doing it for many years,
she got a little burnt out on it.
So when to Dana a mid summer and says,
look,
I don't think I want to do this anymore,
but I'd really love to do something else.
And,
and I've seen kind of what
Jeff's doing in his program.
I realized to go over there and work
with him and kind of learn, you know,
what he's doing. And so Dana pulled
me into the office and said, Hey,
what do you think about this idea?
And it took me literally a half second
to say a hundred percent onboard.
This woman, I mean, as you probably know,
is about as attention to detail and
passionate about her work as anybody.
And really my positioning,
unlike the, the, the name,
the golden snitch is an advocate to our
athletes to make sure our athletes are
successful under the program.
Not that they fail under the program.
It's definitely the wrong
nickname. It's just catchy. It is.
It's unfortunately catchy. Again, I'm all,
I'm all good with it at a roll back. But,
uh, the real golden snitches,
Victor Conti, he's the
Golden Snitch, right? Yeah.
I mean, I was actually
a see that. I can see,
because he was a guy who
was giving guys steroids.
You were a guy that was always
catching people. Correct.
So it's the wrong moniker. Yeah. Correct.
Giving them steroids and
then talking about it after,
right? Yeah. That's a snitch.
Yeah. That's the golden stage.
Not You, man, but it's all good.
I was hoping shop with you
call him up later in this show,
but I could do anything to him,
but it'd be interesting to look at him in
the face. He would say, I'm sorry, Bro.
Sorry.